even the idea that men need women men do
not need women men do not Jesus did not
get married he did not have kids he
didn't do it some of the greatest Saints
did not get married and they did not
have kids women should not be rewarded
with marriage unless they deserve it
they should not be rewarded with men's
time and attention and guys we have we
have these women running around like
Bratz I just saw a woman have a full a
grown woman have a fullblown temper
tantrum in an airport I swear we both
missed our flight I missed my flight and
so did she and this woman just got on
her back and started screaming this is
the craziest thing I've ever seen